anime has become a popular subculture
and it's never been easier to discuss
and express your love for your favorite
shows with other people but as fun as
that is there's always been one massive
downside to interacting with fellow
anime fans
interacting with fellow anime fans
discussing anime online may seem like a
harmless activity as from the outside
the anime community looks welcoming to
everyone whether you're young or old
male or female straight or lgbt jojo fan
however online anime discourse can be a
toxic landscape and navigating it
incorrectly may put you at risk of
causing a bigger nuclear fallout since
hiroshima chernobyl and pissing off the
bts fan base but have no fear i'm here
to break down everything you need to
know to give your survival guide to the
etiquette of discussing anime online so
follow this guide and maybe one day
you'll reach your final form like me and
unlock the secrets of dual wielding
lesson one your taste is [ __ ] according
to other anime fans since the dawn of
the first weaves anime fans have tried
to prove that they are superior to their
fellow anime fans and thus their default
state of communication is to [ __ ] on
each other's taste if you hate the show
you don't know what good anime is if you
like a show you're not liking the right
anime if you think a show is just okay
well you might as well have just pissed
on someone's grave anime fans have found
many ways to express their tastes
publicly from lists to three by threes
to more recently tier lists not
realizing that this is just an open
invitation into an active war zone these
things may look like a blank canvas to
express your taste so you can be
leonardo da vinci but really you're just
proving to everyone that you're leonardo
degenerate oh my god because 2022 now
isn't it time we come to accept people's
very taste in anime and allow people to
enjoy what they want no if anime fans
worked together they have the potential
to build a wonderful utopian society
free of judgments and boundaries but
that would mean giving in and allowing
jimmy over here to think meliodus is a
likable protagonist weebs would rather
live in a state of mutually assured
destruction than accepting each other's
taste this is the foundation the
community is built on which is why it's
always socially acceptable to clown on
weebs especially if you're a weeb so
remember the first lesson about having
an opinion on anime is
don't but of course watching anime isn't
the only way to get in touch with your
website as you can also start getting
into japanese culture like their snack
culture which brings me to my friends
over at bokzu boksu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door guys if
you know me i have immaculate food taste
and i gotta say snack culture here in
japan is on another level each boxing
features a new theme providing a gourmet
journey through japan every month the
first box you'll receive is called
seasons of japan it's curated by snack
experts to bring you a taste of japan's
four seasons and a taste of what you can
expect the whole year of bok su to be
like following seasons of japan you'll
receive a new monthly themed box like
the one i'm showing right now as you can
see this month's theme is tanjobi
meaning birthday as it's boxu's sixth
birthday coming up this month and just
take a look at all these fantastic
looking snacks they've provided to
celebrate i think my favorite snack of
this month has got to be the mochi
truffle because god damn it tastes good
oh my god
so if you want to try some awesome
japanese snacks and support my channel
click the link in the description and
use code giggup15 for 15 off your first
boxu order thank you to boxy for
sponsoring us today back to talking
about anime fans because if you must get
involved with them lesson two not all
anime fans are built the same your
interaction may vary greatly depending
on which corner of the anime fandom you
find yourself in now that anime has
gotten popular the safest place to find
refuge is to blend in with the
functional members of society who just
happen to casually dabble in anime they
don't care if saitama can be goku or if
luffy is a better protagonist than gone
they're just here for the fun so you
don't need to worry about anything
however ask yourself what can we discern
from an individual who says they enjoy
games marvel movies light game of
thrones until the last season and is
watching demon slayer that's right
absolutely [ __ ] nothing the downside
to doing this is potentially coming off
as bland because the only thing worse
than having [ __ ] taste is having no
taste unless of course your taste is
shown in anime within the anime fandom
there is no community more loud more
confrontational than shonen fans people
may say that shonen fans arguing over
which show is superior is akin to
monkeys throwing poop at each other but
that might be an unfair comparison
for the monkeys this is because shonen
fans view their lives as a battle anime
and are always ready for a fight as such
they've even developed their own attacks
to bring as much damage to any opposing
takes they need to confront such as the
word mid mid is short for middle but is
used as a powerful counter against any
and all other opinions about anime not
content was simply saying other shows
are bad shonen fans have somehow found a
way to weaponize mediocrity if someone
else thinks the show is good it's mid if
the show is bad it's mid if the show is
boring it's mid if a show is overhyped
it's mid your favorite moment mid the
characters mid mid is used so often that
nobody even knows what mid means anymore
except for the one thing it doesn't mean
which is
mid if this sounds daunting to you there
are some simple defense strategies you
can use against fans of certain shows in
the genre for example if you meet a
demon slayer fan simply show them this
screenshot of nezco the sight of
cleavage will morally terrify them and
they will not know how to act if you
meet an attack on titan fan simply show
them a microsecond of cgi they will
erupt in a fit of rage and you can use
that to escape if you meet a one-piece
fan simply tell them that oda is just a
normal human being they will fall into a
pit of despair the realization that
their favorite author isn't in fact a
deity for foreshadowing the jelly donut
island arc 500 episodes ago with a
shadow of luffy's ass if you meet a
dragon ball fan show them any other
anime this will confuse them if you meet
a seven deadly sins fan simply say i'm
so sorry these are just a few examples
but luckily you won't have to worry as
much about interacting with the wider
anime community as for the most part
they are harmless idol fans are too busy
building a shrine to celebrate a
birthday for a girl who doesn't exist
mecha fans are just happy to find other
people who still watch mecca edgy fans
want you to call them culture in their
desperate attempt to turn being horny
into a personality trait which it is and
isakai fans are the guy who eats
mcdonald's for breakfast lunch and
dinner and wonders why he's getting
morbidly obese even though he
occasionally orders a diet coke lesson
three you are what your avatar is
eventually you may find an anime that
you enjoy immensely and may feel like
you want to express that by picking an
avatar from that show to put on your
social media accounts however it is
highly advised against doing that as
it's a surefire way to make sure nothing
you say ever gets taken seriously ever
again normally you may see this manifest
in some person blindly saying that
dragon ball or jiu-jitsu kaisen or demon
slayer is peak fiction and unmatched by
anything and you think huh i wonder what
kind of person would say such a
hyperbolic statement so you look at the
avatar and surprise surprise it's a
demon slayer avatar
i swear it feels like parody every time
i see it but this is not as bad as the
biggest pitfall any anime fan can fall
into picking a cute anime girl as your
avatar it is scientifically proven that
the more anime and individual watchers
the higher concentration of cute anime
girls that they will see and so will
eventually come to the conclusion that
there is nothing more pure in life than
the smile of a cute anime girl this may
lead people to believe that hiding
behind the mask of a 2d anime girl may
somehow cleanse them off the impurity of
their image online however it only
serves to emphasize their degeneracy as
once a waifu is picked the cuteness of
the anime girl is directly proportionate
to how much of an abomination their
takes are there are some who attempt to
sidestep this by choosing a berserk
vagabond or vinland saga avatar thinking
that this gives them a much more
respectable image than all other people
but unfortunately they forget
that they still have an anime profile
picture lesson 4 be careful where you
are there are many places you can run
into anime fans online and depending on
where you do the vibe culture and
etiquette may totally be different
nowadays many fans stick to their
private discord servers where they can
freely discuss their favorite anime in
the safety of a closed group youtube is
another place where you can see would-be
critics give their opinions about anime
but if you want to get involved in the
conversation itself good luck getting
past the top comments which will
inevitably be a funny quote from the
video or a comment from just some guy
without a mustache if those
conversations don't seem mentally
stimulating enough many venture off to a
space like reddit my anime list or anime
planets generally the people here have
seen more anime than your average user
leading to potentially more stimulating
discussions however that is rarely the
case and in time they will realize that
the only difference between them and
youtube comments is that youtube
comments actually realize that they are
a bunch of apes but this is all nothing
compared to twitter a website full of
people so free thinking so open-minded
that brains have literally fallen out
twitter is a place where people can air
out their most private and intimate
thoughts you'd only share to your
closest friends and relatives whoms you
absolutely trust in the completely
public space that anyone can see
discussing anime on twitter is like
taking a dump in the urinal yeah you can
technically do it but why would you ever
think that that's a good idea this is
the place where you can see anime takes
that make you question some people's
ability for sentient thought the problem
is that most people are barely able to
articulate themselves in normal
conversations let alone with 280
characters the secret here is to only
have opinions on the extreme end
normally people may refer to this as a
hot take but twitter users often use
this opportunity to make a set yourself
on fire take if you're scared doing this
will offend someone don't worry as
twitter has its own version of
sturgeon's law ninety percent of
everything you say will offend someone
this may make it sound like there is no
safe refuge to discuss your passions
online but fear not as there is still
one place pure and untainted that may be
the last bastion of hope where you can
have constructive discussions with
strangers online the pornhub comment
section and that's everything you need
to know about interacting with anime
fans soon enough you'll be a master at
this and realize that you don't even
watch anime anymore you just make fun of
people who do online failing all this
there is one surefire way to protect
yourself from any anime fan a secret
technique passed down through the ages
that is a surefire way to let people
know that your tastes are superior and
immaculate compared to any anime fan you
ever talk to final lesson
just say you read manga
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too alpha
sigma basil dysfunctional degenerate
elephant flabberwocky ivito jeff hayne
patchett tony stark waltergeist vt and
everyone else my patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible as you can see i am
back in my old studio right now yes i
have returned to england yeah i'm just
gonna be back here for a bit you know
catching up with friends and family and
more importantly sorting out my wedding
which is hopefully happening soon i'm
going to be doing a lot of traveling in
the upcoming months so get used to
seeing a new background because uh it
might change on the fly very suddenly
i'm still gonna be working as much as
possible on the go so for now you
shouldn't see any difference in the
upload schedule anyway though that's it
from me for today i've been gig uk and
i'll see you all next time